MALE SPEAKER 1: It
is a great honor
to have you here at Google.
You are the person I'm
most excited about hosting
in many years.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 1: We're
very grateful to you
for the generosity of your
time and your presence.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So
the topic of today--
I know at this level
people are signing topics,
so they come here
not really knowing
what we're talking about.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Sometimes.
MALE SPEAKER 1: The
topic is inner connection
and meditation.
Changing the world
from the inside out.
Cool, huh?
[LAUGHTER]
So before we talk about
that, medication and changing
the world, I want to ask
you a few simple questions
about yourself, so
the audience will
know you a little bit more.
So the first question-- it
sounds like a kid's question--
but it's a good one,
which is, how is it
like to be the Karmapa?
What is the best thing
and the worst thing
about being a Karmapa?
[LAUGHTER]
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH KARMAPA:
Best thing and worst thing--
better to use--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: So first
of all, I'd like
to just say hello and
welcome to everyone.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: When I was
recognized as the Karmapa,
I was seven years old.
And generally, at that time,
before I was recognized,
my family had already
a very strong custom
of having great faith
towards the master who
was known as Karmapa,
considering that master
to be a very important
precious master.
So we all felt that way
about this individual who
is known as Karmapa,
but none of us
had the expectation
that I was going
to become that individual.
So I became the Karmapa
in a very sudden manner.
And at first I
thought it was just
going to be a great fun time.
[LAUGHTER]
To become the Karmapa.
I would have many opportunities
to play and many things
to play with and so forth.
That was my first impression.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: But it
didn't turn out that way.
And what I would
say is that, if I
had time to prepare to
become the Karmapa, then
it would've been fairly
easy and approachable.
But without any time to
prepare, it is very difficult.
And the way that
happened for me is
that I didn't have
any time to prepare.
Everything happened
very suddenly.
And there were a
lot of adjustments
to make that I wasn't prepared
for-- parting from my parents
for long periods of time, and
there were many other things
that I had to give up.
So in the end, I found
out that it's not fun.
Quite difficult.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So what's
the best thing about being--
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH KARMAPA:
What's the best thing?
Best thing.
[LAUGHTER]
The best-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: I think
one really good thing
about being the Karmapa
is the opportunity
that it has afforded
me to recognize
my own responsibilities.
I think that's-- obviously
I believe everyone has great
responsibilities to everyone
else and to the planet,
but a lot of people don't have
an opportunity to recognize how
much responsibility they have.
So I feel that the
role of Karmapa
has given me an opportunity to
recognize the fact that I have
a lot of responsibility to
try to benefit others, as well
as the entire environment,
the world and all
of its inhabitants,
as best I can.
And being in this position has
helped me to recognize that,
and I would say
that's a good thing.
MALE SPEAKER 1: That's
a beautiful answer.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So talk about
responsibility, my friend.
You're a young man.
You're 29 years old.
So what's the most
important thing
the Karmapa has to do
for the next 29 years?
HIS HOLINESS THE
17TH KARMAPA: Wow.
29 years.
I'm already 29 years.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Whereas Google
is a very organized company
with great far reaching and very
specific plans for the future,
including the long term future
like having a 25 year plan,
a 10 year plan--
MALE SPEAKER 1: Our
long time is six months.
[LAUGHTER]
But yes, more than
that sometimes.
TRANSLATOR: I'm not like that.
I don't build very specific
plans for the long term.
I feel like I'm building up
to that in a gradual way.
So for now I don't have
any specific plans--
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Moment to moment.
TRANSLATOR: For that far out.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
That's a good answer.
Thank you.
It's good because
if moment to moment
you're always doing
the right thing--
HIS HOLINESS THE
17TH KARMAPA: Yes.
Try to.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
You're very humble.
So I want to shift gears now to
talk about practice, meditation
and Buddhism.
So the topic of our
conversation is inner connection
and meditation.
And what practical advice do
you have for secular Americans--
people in this room and people
watching this-- by the way,
a million people will
be watching this.
So what advice do you have
for the good people on how
they can develop
their inner connection
and their meditation.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Inner connection.
Meditation.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: So the
21st century is
a time of great development,
great improvement
on many fronts, and
also great change.
Because of the very
rapid developments
that are happening, sometimes
we feel overwhelmed by that.
And the question
becomes how do we
balance a sense of
inner peace in our minds
with this continuing external
development and change.
So meditation is something that
can assist in that very much.
It can help us to
stabilize our minds,
bring peace to our minds,
and have more control
over our minds so that
we're not overwhelmed
by this continuous change
and development that's
happening externally.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Many
forms of our happiness
actually depend upon outer
things, external objects.
But the nice thing about
meditation and what I think
is one of the most
important things
that meditation does for us
is it helps us to connect
with a happiness,
a peace of mind,
a sense of satisfaction that
is not at all contingent
upon external objects, but that
comes from within ourselves.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: For example, a
lot of meditation techniques
focus on immediate
phenomena that are already
present within ourselves.
Of course, working
with the breath
is a very common
technique in meditation
and the breath is something
that is always with us for
as long as we're alive.
And so sometimes
we don't recognize
these precious natural
resources that we
have with us all the time.
So from one
perspective, meditation
helps us pay attention and
care to these natural resources
that we have, which in
turn helps us to relax.
And from another
perspective, it also
helps us engender a natural
sense of wonderment or awe
or joyfulness about what is
precious within us already.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: So
meditation isn't just
about relaxing and
helping us to de-stress.
It's something that can
increase our awareness,
can help us develop more
mindfulness, but not only that.
It can help us develop a deeper
sense of joy and appreciation.
What do we appreciate?
We not only appreciate
the natural environment
that is around us, but
we, through meditation,
heighten our appreciation
of our own bodies.
And many other things.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So at what point
does kindness and compassion
develop?
So we just look at the wonder of
the inner phenomenon and outer.
Does then kindness
and compassion
arise naturally or does
it need extra work?
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Well
firstly, I think
that meditation is something
that naturally connects us
with who we are in
an uncontrived way.
So many things we
do in our lives
are contrived attempts at
becoming something else.
But meditation brings us back to
the natural state of who we are
and what we're made out of.
And I think that can become a
stepping stone for developing
further qualities.
For example, I mentioned
awareness earlier.
The awareness that we
develop through meditation
is an awareness of the
reality that we all
depend upon each other.
For example, when
we become more aware
of our breath in meditation,
then we naturally
become more aware of the fact
that our breath isn't just
this autonomously
existent thing.
It depends on other
phenomenon in order to arise.
We might develop
an appreciation,
for example, that
the air we breathe
comes to us from
plants, and so forth.
And so in this way, meditation
deepens our appreciation
with the interdependent
reality of things.
We make a much
stronger connection
with that appreciation
and that becomes
the springboard for compassion.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I like that.
So I'm going to ask about
mindfulness-- your opinion
of mindfulness in the West.
As you know, mindfulness
has become very popular
in the West, especially
in companies.
Even here in Google
we have a program
called "Search Inside Yourself",
which is based on mindfulness.
And beyond that we're also doing
things we're talking about.
Shamatha-- clearing the mind.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH], insight,
and [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
innocent compassion.
So I want to know your opinion
of the mindfulness movement
in the West, and
whether there's anything
you think should be
encouraged and anything
we should be careful about.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Mindfulness.
Can you talk a little
bit of mindfulness.
Everybody have mindfulness.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR:
MALE SPEAKER 1: In Pali, I
think it's [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: So just
to say a little bit
about mindfulness itself.
Of course mindfulness is a
very well-known phenomenon
these days and I
think most of us
have a basic understanding
of what it means.
But you could say for
nontraditional perspective
or from commonly presented
perspective of what's
in the Buddha's
teachings we can say
that an essential meaning of my
influences that it teaches us
how to take care
of our mind or how
to give our mind some
guidance so in the beginning
our mind has these
traits which are quite
similar to a small child small
child needs to small children
need some guidance
and some boundaries
if they don't have any
guidance or boundaries
and they can get into trouble
so mindfulness is a method
to take good care of
our mind and give it
some kind of guidelines.
And in that way, understand
it's true state more clearly.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I have
so questions for you,
but I promised them I'd give
them time to ask you questions.
I'm trying to cut down my
question-- my one question.
I'm interested to know about
what you think about science.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Science?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yes, so-- we
have a common friend, Richard
[INAUDIBLE].
I know we're going to visit him.
He is a pioneer of the
newer science of meditation.
So I'm interested to
know are you excited,
are you concerned, that
meditation is becoming
a field of scientific inquiry?
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Of course
science and spirituality
have different
ways of proceeding
to their respective goals.
And we don't need to have
the same way of proceeding,
and we don't need to merge these
two disciplines or fields such
that they then share
the exact same goals
or have the exact
same methodologies
or produce the
exact same results.
However, I think that they can
be beneficial to each other.
Now, I'm not sure whether
it's important or not
in terms of the
notion of science
being able to prove the ideas
of Buddhism, for example.
I'm not really sure
whether that's important
or not, but what I would say
is that not only Buddhism
but many ancient spiritual
traditions have been spending
all of this time
throughout history focusing
on the inner world
of the mind, and I
think that can be a good
resource for further research
that can be used by science.
In any case, both science and
the great spiritual traditions
share the same
goal of performing
a good service for
the world and making
a better future for everyone.
So I think there's a lot
of harmonious opportunities
that can be explored there.
And I myself have been to
the Mind and Life conference
a few times, and I see
a lot of potential.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So I'm
going to shift gears now
to changing the world.
[LAUGHTER]
Specifically, how you
are changing the world.
You recently announced
that you were
established full ordination
for women in your lineage.
To us that's very exciting.
Can you tell us more about it?
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Right now, I feel
like I'm taking small steps
or beginning to
take small steps.
In Tibet, as well as many
other Buddhist countries
throughout history, women
have faced difficulty
in achieving the status of
full monastic ordination.
And there are some
areas where people
have been striving to make
improvements and change this.
And in some other
areas the status quo
is being allowed to
remain up until now.
But from the
Tibetan perspective,
it's been hundreds
of years since women
have been able to achieve
or receive full ordination.
And I think that this is a very
important situation to remedy.
His Holiness the
Dalai Lama, as well as
many other Tibetan
Buddhist leaders,
have been putting
efforts into this.
And therefore I think
it's very important.
Because of course, there are
many, many women practitioners
of Buddhism who have
great faith in the dharma
and should be properly seated
as leaders in their communities,
and the status of
full ordination
is a very important
position of leadership.
And so I think it's worthy of
effort from that perspective,
and therefore I'm going
to put as much effort
in accordance with
whatever abilities
I have to help make
this change, to help
bring this change about.
In general, these
days we're observing
a lot of rapidly changing
dynamics regarding
women and leadership.
We've observed various countries
having female heads of state,
female leaders of
government, presidents,
prime ministers, and so forth.
And ongoing discussions
in certain countries
about whether that would be
permissible, in certain other
countries about whether
that would be possible
and when it would
happen and so forth.
And I really see the
status of full ordination
as a similar level of
leadership for women to hold
and that's why I think
it's important for society.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
You're very humble.
You do a lot.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
You're very humble.
That's big.
But to you-- you know
what would be really cool?
For the 18th Karmapa
to be a woman.
[LAUGHTER]
HIS HOLINESS THE
17TH KARMAPA: Ooh.
MALE SPEAKER 1: You
saw this here first.
[LAUGHTER]
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Since there's 900
years of history behind me,
I don't know if I can make an
immediate change, of course.
I think I might have to meditate
for a longer time in order
to be able to do that.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: So I think from
a Buddhist perspective,
if we look at the
teachings of Buddhism,
there's no problem
at all in that,
in having the subsequent
Karmapa being a female.
But from a societal
perspective, I sometimes
wonder what kind of
difficulties there would be.
MALE SPEAKER 1: That's
very thoughtful.
Let's see.
I have two more questions
before we open up.
So the three things
I admire about you.
And there are more than
three, but the three big ones.
I admire your progressive,
your open mind.
I admire your work
towards women's rights.
And the third thing I admire
about you is environmentalism
You're known to be a very
avid environmentalist.
So the question here is,
my friend-- Your Holiness--
[LAUGHTER]
HIS HOLINESS THE
17TH KARMAPA: Yes.
No problem, no problem.
MALE SPEAKER 1: What is your
vision for the environment?
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Sometimes I
call myself Your Loneliness.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 1: In
front of camera,
I must call you Your Holiness.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Oh yeah.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR:
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Sorry.
TRANSLATOR: No, no.
I'm sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Your Sorry-ness.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Sorry-ness.
[LAUGHTER]
TRANSLATOR: So the
environmental issue
is of course a global issue.
It's a huge issue for
everyone on the planet
and for the planet itself.
And therefore I see my
activities in relation
to this as very small,
humble activities.
But nevertheless, Tibet is a
little bit of a special place
in terms of the environment.
Particularly for Asia, it's
known as a treasury of rivers
because it's the source
of so many Asian rivers.
And it's known also
as the third pole,
because of the
important role that it's
glaciers and so on play.
So since Tibet is this
very important place
for the environment,
I think it's good
if monks and nuns can begin
some of the transformations that
need to occur in terms
of our living style.
And monks the nuns have a
special opportunity and ability
to lead the people and lead
the way in this regard.
So therefore, I'm
doing the best I
can to help change some of our
practices at our monasteries
and make the monks and
nuns more aware of what
needs to change with
regard to the environment,
with the wish that that will
slowly begin to extend outward.
So things haven't gone along
perfectly in the exact manner
that I would have hoped, but
we're making our best efforts
and progressing
along slowly in this.
Basically with the environment,
the important point for us
to understand is that
not changing anything
about our lifestyle, yet doing
a few things here and there
for the environment is
not really going to help.
That's not going
to be sufficient.
What's required is the change
in the way that we live.
A change in our style of living.
And in order to do
that, we have to work
on transforming our motivation.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I have one
more question for His Holiness
before I open up to the floor.
So if you want to, you can
start lining up now at the mike.
So the last question
for Your Holiness.
What can we, Google and the
Silicon Valley, do to help you?
HIS HOLINESS THE
17TH KARMAPA: Oh.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: This is my first
time visiting Google today,
so I'm already overwhelmed
by its vastness.
And basically I just want
to say thank you to Google
for having me as a guest here.
Google, of course, is a
very influential company.
And it's doing very
positive influential things
in terms of it's
practices in relation
to society and relation
to human well being.
And therefore I'd like to offer
these words and sentiments
of praise toward Google for
that and thank them for that.
But other than
that, I don't have
any special requests to make.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
Anything I can for you,
you tell me off stage.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: OK, privately.
Privately.
[LAUGHTER] Thank you, thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So we
have some Dory questions,
and so best alternate life
question and then Dory
question.
Yes, my friend.
JD.
AUDIENCE: Your Holiness,
thank you for your presence.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: On the
topic of meditation,
I have a couple of questions.
I'm a student of the
Six Yogas of Naropa
and been learning about the
practice of tummo meditation.
And so I wondered
if you could talk
about the benefits of tummo
meditation and perhaps
any advice for a
westerner wishing
to practice tummo-- inner fire.
HIS HOLINESS THE
17TH KARMAPA: Wow.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
It's a hot question.
[LAUGHTER]
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Firstly, I haven't
done any practice of tummo
for myself, so I can't
explain in great detail
about that practice.
But what I would
say in general is
that there's different
ways in Buddhism
we approach taming our
mind or calming our mind.
One is in reliance on the
prana, or the inner winds,
and then one is by working
with the mind itself.
So working with the mind
itself to tame our mind
is the safe way to
relate to our mind
in the context of meditation.
It takes a little bit more time.
You need a little bit
more patience in order
to transform your mind that
way, but if you stick with it
you can do it and
there's less danger.
The Six Dharmas
of Naropa, and in
particular the
practice of tummo,
falls into the
category of relying
on the pranas, or inner winds,
in order to transform the mind.
And that's a more
dangerous approach.
You get to the desired result,
it is said, in a faster way.
But because you're
going faster, it's
also more dangerous
at the same time.
So greater caution
needs to be applied
when taking that approach.
But if you have
that proper caution
and if you regard
that practice not just
as being about inner heat
or something like this,
but as a method for further
enhancing and establishing
peace of mind, and
peace in our mind,
then such practices can
definitely be beneficial.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So
this is a question
that was sent through the
net-- our internal internet.
This is asked by [INAUDIBLE].
When we or our loved
ones face suffering
from incurable diseases,
disability, or death,
how can we best
ease the suffering
and help with healing?
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: So yes,
we do have difficulty
accepting very difficult
situations that befall us,
including death.
Generally speaking
of course, death
is a part of the
natural cycle of things,
even though we don't
want to experience it.
But by virtue of being born
into this body that means
this body is going to die.
So therefore I think
some type of training
in the recognition of the
inevitability of death
is very important and
can be very beneficial.
Some type of training and
employment of our imagination
to get used to
this idea of death,
and to regard our own human
life as simply a process that
includes death.
And that way we can come
to see, if we become
familiar with
thinking in this way,
we can come to see death
not as an insult or instance
of becoming conquered, but as
a natural part of the process
that is our life.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: And to
help us do this,
we can use our imagination
to regard one day
as being like a whole lifetime.
AUDIENCE: Your Holiness,
thank you for your time today.
In your opinion, what's
the greatest threat
to our planet and
our human existence?
HIS HOLINESS THE
17TH KARMAPA: Wow.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Well, there are
many dangers to the world
and to beings on the planet that
we could think of and identify.
Of course, sometimes there's
terrible natural disasters
that occur and so forth.
But I think even more
severe than all of that
is the harms that are
inflicted on the planet
through the selfishness
of human beings.
If we look at how many changes
the planet has undergone
since the time humans
have been inhabiting it,
it's a relatively
short time span,
but we can see that there's
been great changes that
have been brought to
the planet and have
been caused to the planet
by the conduct of humans.
If this was just a
natural cycle of change,
I think things would be changing
at a much different rate.
So therefore I think
generally speaking
that if we don't find
a way to transform
our own desires as human beings
or put a limit on our desires,
then that spells great
danger for the planet.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
So this is another
Dory question.
This one comes from Doug.
Buddhism has been a presence
in America for 150 years
and in the past decades
has become widespread.
So given that, might we expect
a homegrown super meditator,
some sort of America Milarepa?
[LAUGHTER]
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: America.
America all busy, yeah?
[LAUGHTER]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Well, I think such
a thing as definitely possible.
There's nothing
impossible about it.
On the other hand,
my general feeling
is that there are more
obstacles then there
are favorable conditions
for such a thing
to arise at this
point, because there's
a lot of materialistic focus
in general in our society,
and so forth.
So there are some obstacles.
At the same time,
what can happen
is that sometimes no matter
how strong the obstacles are,
then the individuals
ability grows that much more
to counter those obstacles.
So nothing is impossible
in that regard.
But another thing
to note is that we
may have great spiritual
practitioners among us,
but maybe they're
not very well known
or don't have a lot of fame.
And at the same time,
we have to acknowledge
that just because
individuals are famous,
that doesn't mean they're
necessarily great in terms
of their spiritual qualities.
So I think that
the identification
of a great spiritual
master needs
to happen very personal level.
And we might not be
able to spot them
in the same way we
would spot a superhero.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Anybody in the audience
who turns out to be a great
meditator or superhero,
please come talk to us after
the talk so we can identify you.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Your Holiness, it's
been a great pleasure for me
to meet you in person.
I watched the documentary
about your previous incarnation
and how they find your
present incarnation
and I find it very fascinating.
My question today is
that, personally I
feel that there's a great
loss of ancient wisdoms
despite of the human
advancement in recent years.
It's become much
harder for people
to pursue spiritually and have
control over their lives--
to go into the mountain to
meditate 10, 20 or more years
to reach spiritual
enlightenment.
So I was wondering what's
your advice for people
who find it hard to
control of their lives,
and do you personally find it
harder to pursue spiritually
because of the tremendous amount
of responsibilities and burdens
that you have?
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: Well to answer
your later question first,
I do find it difficult myself
to practice spirituality
in this modern age.
From one perspective,
you could say
that I live in a
spiritual environment
because I'm a leader of
a spiritual tradition
and so I have certain
elements of spirituality
in my physical environment.
But from another perspective,
because I'm a spiritual leader,
these days you have
to deal with all
kinds of politics and comings
and goings and relations that
are sometimes
unsavory and so forth.
So what that leads
me to realize is
that there's a great
deal that's contingent
upon our own motivation.
If we don't have a strong,
positive motivation
from our own side, then
it's very difficult
to practice spirituality
because the environment has
such a strong manipulative
effect on our mind.
So sometimes when people are
in a very peaceful environment
where there's not a
lot of distraction
or maybe not a lot of
outer a development
in that particular area, they
can practice spirituality well.
But if they go to a place
where everything is abundant
and there are more distractions,
then their spiritual practice
starts to fade away.
And I think that this
is my own shortcoming
as well that perhaps I have,
just as much as anyone else.
And therefore I think
it's very important for us
to create a supportive
environment for ourselves that
matches our intention to
practice spirituality.
In the traditional
Buddhist text,
they talk about going to an
isolated place to meditate,
for example.
In a modern context, when you're
sharing an apartment or house
with another person,
even if there's only
two people inside
the residence, you
talk about how you're
going to split up the space
so you can have your
own private area.
So in the same way I think
it's very important for us
to create physical
space for ourselves
so that we can do
things such as meditate.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Thank you very much.
This next question is relevant
to what you just said.
It is, what are the most
effective meditation
techniques that you have used?
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: I don't have
any special techniques
that I rely on in a
continuous way all the time.
Meditation techniques
are something
that just kind of
come and go for me.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
MALE SPEAKER 1: What's a
current technique that you--
[LAUGHTER]
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Very smart.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Dealing
with difficuly people.
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Current technique.
Wow.
Forgot.
I actually, I don't have
any special technique.
Maybe just like--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: So if you
could call it a technique,
I find that the
main thing I do is,
when I notice that I'm
feeling strong emotions,
that I try to not follow
after the emotionality of it,
but instead sustain a feeling
of relaxation within that.
MALE SPEAKER 1: That's good.
You have the last live question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for visiting us,
and hope you come back again.
My question is, Silicon Valley's
known for its innovation,
and we consider
that innovation has
a lot of similarities to
meditation-- deep focus,
searching for answers.
But at the same time, it also
has a lot of material focus.
Do you think there's a
trade off between innovation
in the Western sense versus
doing good for humanity
through meditation?
HIS HOLINESS THE
17TH KARMAPA: Mm-hmm.
TRANSLATOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
TRANSLATOR: There
definitely can be
a lot of overlap
between innovation
and what you might
call a wholesome
intention or pure intention
of the path of spirituality.
In fact, if we
look at innovation
I think we can see that most
of the great brilliant ideas
from the innovators of society
occur to them when their minds
are relaxed and open.
And in the same way, the best
of our wholesome intentions
and altruistic
states of our heart
occur when our minds
are open and spacious.
So I think these two,
innovation and pure intention,
are close cousins or
relatives with each other.
When we appreciate our
interconnectedness,
we can further develop
natural altruism,
which can be known
by another name
that we might call
responsibility.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Your
Holiness, any last words
for the audience?
HIS HOLINESS THE
17TH KARMAPA: No, no.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Thank you
so much for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
HIS HOLINESS THE 17TH
KARMAPA: Thank you.
Thank you.